ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะหรือจับกล้องก่อนค่ะได้ค่ะจะได้เห็น
ครูเอ๋
ชัดๆนะคะ
โอเคผู้หญิงเค้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 15 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายนปี 2 เท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
2565 นะคะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ 202
นี้นะคะทำไมเธอ
เวลาคุยอิ๋งตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วตอนนี้
3:00 น
12 นาทีค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 12 นาทีนะคะค่ะ
[เพลง]
เป็นอะไรคะรู้เห
รอค
[เพลง]
เมื่อคืน
กลืนตรงนี้จะมีหลอดเล็กหลอดอาหารอยู่ตรง
ไหนอ่ะ
You ข้างในข้างในข้างในนะคะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
ว่าให้ดูรูปนะคะ
[เพลง]
มานี่ก่อนนะกันอ่ะ
เวลาที่เรากินใช่มั้ยคะกินแล้วลงไปที่นี่
เป็นหลอดอาหาร
อาหารก็จะลงมั้ย
ลงไปที่ไหนปากกา
ปากกาครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋ยหาปากกาเหรอคะผู้หญิง
หยุดรอก่อนหยุด
รู๋หาปากกาเจอรึยังคะเจอแล้วปากกา
วันเวลาที่ลำกินใช่ไหมคะเข้าหลอดอาหาร
แล้วก็ลงมาไหนอ่านี่ไงนะๆอาหารก็จะลงมา
ข้างล่างอันนี้ก่อนอาหารจะไปว่าหลอดอาหาร
ให้นะคะได้ค่ะหลอดอาหารอยู่ตรงไหนในรูป
หลอดอาหารเนี่ยอยู่ตรงนิ
ไอ้ตัวนี้นั่งตัวนี้ก่อนตัวนี้ครูหญิงรู้
ไหมอ่ะอะไร
ไม่รู้ค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรคะอันนี้อะกระเพาะ
พูดสั้นๆ
กระเพาะ
บีพูดยาวๆด้วยเหรอคะ
กระทะอาหารขอ
เวลาทำช่องคะกินใช่มั้ยผู้หญิงกินปลาปลา
ก็จะอยู่ข้างในใช่ไหมสีน้ำมันดีกว่าเนาะ
ค่ะจะได้เห็นคักๆอ้ะกินปลาปลาก็อยู่ที่
นี่ใช่ไหมคะปลาจะลงมาที่กระเพาะอาหารใช่
ลงมาที่กระเพาะอาหาร
เราก็ตรงนี้น่ะพร้อมกินกินอ่ะตอนนี้จะตรง
นี้นะคะเวลาจะกินลงไปเขาก็จะเปิดใช่ไหมคะ
เวลาเราเอามาใช้แล้วกินเสร็จแล้วเขาก็จะ
ปิดหน้าเปิดได้ปิดได้ใช่เขาก็จะเข้ามาปิด
พระมีกระเพาะอาหารครูเอ๋เนี่ยกินกิน
มาก
ก็เลยองค์
หาในหรือหรือกินไม่ดีไม่รู้เหมือนที่กิน
ไม่ดีก็จะง่วงนอนเลยนะคะรู้เหรอตอนนี้
มาย 15:00 นอ่ะในกระเพาะอาหารครูเอ๋ก็มี
อาหารอาหารอาหารอาหารอาหารช้ามากๆเหรอคะ
เพราะว่ากระเพาะอาหารมันต้องมีน้ำขอให้
ครูหญิงวุฒิน้ำย่อยเป็นยังไงคะเดี๋ยวคุย
ให้ดูน้ำย่อยนะคะน้ำย่อยเนี่ยออกจะสีสี
นี่อะโอเคสีอะไรน้ำย่อยจะสีเขียวๆๆค่ะ
น้ำยอยเวลาเรากินแล้วก็มีปลาลงไปน้ำย่อย
จะออกมานะ
ก็ร่อยหรอคะยอยๆๆๆ
ย่อยปลาก็จะเล็กๆๆ
ลง
[เพลง]
งั้นเนี่ยตอนนี้กำลังย้อยย้อยพ่อกำลัง
ย่อยย่อยเราก็จะง่วงนอน
นะคะเกาะเพราะอาหารที่เป็นอวัยวะใช่ไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงใช่ค่ะกระเพาะอาหารเป็นอวัยวะ
อวัยวะอาวะภายในหรืออวัยวะภายนอก
อวัยวะภายในค่ะค่ะอวัยวะภายในนะคะ
นักเรียนดูตัวนี้ก่อนนะคะเดี๋ยวคุยให้ดู
อยู่อาไร
ถ้าที่นี่เป็นอันนี้เป็น End  Call ใช่
ไหมคะซออันนี้ป่าใช่ไหมคะ
บาทเห็นเห็นไหมคะนี่ถ้าเห็นค่ะแล้วก็อัน
นี้เป็นตัวนะคะคุยมันเห็นครึ่งเดียวนะคะ
ทั้งขยับมาพรุ่งนี้
เดี๋ยวกูอีกวัดใหม่นะคะได้ค่ะรัว s  n ลบ
ลบก่อน
เดี๋ยว
วาดใหม่วัดหมาย
อันใหญ่ไหมเห็นไหมค่ะอย่าได้แต่คุยก็ต้อง
ว่าชั้นนี้อ่ะอ่ะอ่ะทำไมเป็นสีแดง
มาว่า
โอเค RC น้ำงานโอเคค่ะถ้าอันนี้เป็นคอค่ะ
ขอเป็นตัว
เป็นแขกบาปตัว
มาตัวเอาเอะอะอันนี้จะเป็นข้างนอกใช่ไหม
คะผู้หญิง
ใส่ค่ะหน้าที่เรากำลังพูดโอเคอันนี้หลอด
อาหาร
โห้ร้านอาหารแล้วก็
อยู่ฝั่งไหนอ้าแบบนี้
เมื่อโห
มันเนี้ยกระเพาะอาหาร
อยู่ข้างในอยู่ข้างอยากไปอ่ะทักแขนหัว
จมูกป่าตัวอันนี้อวัยวะ
ภายนอก
มองเห็นใช่ไหมคะชายมองเห็นแต่ถ้ากระเพาะ
อาหาร
กระเพาะอาหาร
เป็นอวัยวะภายใน
ข่าวแล้วก็เปิด
ถึงจะมองเห็นถึงจะมองเห็นนะคะวันนี้ครู
หญิงกับครูเอ๋ก็จะให้ดูอวัยวะ
ภายใด
ครูเอ๋ชาแล้วก็เอาออกมาให้ดูเหรอคะเด็ก
ขาดแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็เอาออก
ไปดูทำไมนักเรียนจะได้รู้
ฮะโอเคค่ะ
สำหรับนักเรียนดู
อุ้ยเอ๋เอากลับยังไง
ได้ล่ะอ่ะเจ๊นะคะครูเอกต้องลบก่อนนะคะผู้
หญิงค่ะลบตรงนี้ก่อน
นพๆโอเค
นี่ค่ะเดี๋ยวจะให้ดูอวัยวะอวัยวะภายในนะ
คะเมื่อกี้นักเรียนดูกระเพาะ
กระเพาะอาหารจากอวัยวะภายในมีมัดม่า
โอ๊ยแล้วครูเอ๋จะผ่าก็เปิดให้ดูได้ค่ะครู
ไม่ได้ผ่าครูเอ๋วาด
[เพลง]
หมู่บ้านเอกดูรูปแล้วก็ว่า
เก่งค่ะ
อันแรกเลยแล้วกันค่ะจากค่ะคนเนาะข้างบน
แล้วก็ลงลงลงใช่ไหมค่ะน่านอันนี้อะเป็น
อวัยวะภายในใช่ไหมคะนายค่ะถ้าตรงนี้เนี่ย
เป็นหัวเนาะ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเอาผมออกเอาหนังออกเจอกะโหลกน้ำแข็ง
ตลกมันจิ๊กซอว์นะฮะเปิดตลกๆมา
เธออะไร
สมองค่ะรู้ตรงไหนคะสมองครูเอ๋ทั้งหมด
เนี่ยค่ะ
อีกมีสีฟ้าสีน้ำเงินสีเขียวสีแดงสีม่วง
ทั้งหมดเรียกว่าสมองเหรอคะจะหมองค่ะเพื่อ
สมองคู๋มีสีมากๆ
ทำไมมีสมองมักมุด
สมองคนเนี่ยมีมีมีมีสมองก้านสมอ
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋รู้จักจากก้านสมอง
เป็นสมองที่ 1 แล้วก็มีสมอง
อยู่ตรงนี้แต่ก็มีสมองตรงนี้อ่าแต่ว่าไม่
เป็นไรเราไม่ได้เรียนหมอพูดสมองโอเคกูแต่
เรามีสมองสมองสมองหลายๆแบบรวมใกล้ๆชิ้น
หน้ามีเพราะว่ามีสมองนะมีสมองตีบขวาสมอง
จีบซ้าย
ใช่ไหมมีขวามีซ้ายมีก้านสมองมีสมองตรงนี้
จริงๆมีมีทั้งหมด 3 ชนะ 3 นะคะสมองมี 3
แบ่งแบ่ง
แล้วก็สมองเนี่ยผู้หญิงรู้ไหมอ่ะอ้าอัน
นี้มือกูเองมือซ้ายผู้หญิงด้วยซ้ายมือขวา
อีกมือขวามือซ้ายกะและสมองขวา
ครับ
ทำไมมือซ้ายไม่ใช่สมองซ้ายเหมือนกันมือ
ซ้ายถ้าผู้หญิงอยากจะให้สมองขวาแข็งแรงทำ
อะไรก็ขอให้ยาชา
ถ้าครูหญิงอยากให้สมองซ้ายแข็งแรงขยับมือ
ขวาเพราะมันตรงข้ามกันโอ้โห
งั้นน่ะคะขยับสองมือ
สมองความสมาะิกับสมองขวาสมองซ้ายแข็งแรง
เก่ง
ขยะไปด้วยอ่ะฟังรู้เองโอเคไหมผู้หญิงนัก
เรียนจะ
นักเรียนฟังแล้วขยับด้วยได้ไหมน้อย
นักเรียนขยับเบอร์อย่าขยับมาด้วยนะคะขยับ
เลย 20,000
comeback ำหแฟหรือบางทีมีมีอะไรนะครับ
บีบ
บีบอ่ะ
มาได้
ควีนผู้หญิงไม่เป็นไรกูหญิงก็บีบนวดและ
นวดไม่มีตุ๊กตาปี่ตุ๊กตาได้มั้ยคะๆๆ
มือก็แข็งแรงจะมาที่นี่มือแข็งแรงสมอง
เก่งจริงๆค่ะ
แล้วมีอวัยวะหมดหรือยังลืม
ก่อนโอเคสมอง
เขาบอกสมอง
สมองต้องต้องอ่านหนังสือ
อ่านบ่อยๆใช่ไหม
ก็อ่านหนังสือ
ต้อง
คิดอะไรอะไรอะไร
คลิปบ่อยๆสมองดีนะคะ
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋จากสมองเมื่อกี้เราพูดถึง
หลอดอาหารไปแล้วนะคะครูเอกให้ดูอันนี้
ก่อนข้างไหน
โห
เป็นไข่เอาทางรูปเล็กๆนิดนึงได้ไหมคะไม่
ได้ได้ไหมคุยดูก่อน
เดี๋ยวขนาดค่ะวันนี้น่าจะได้อันนี้กูอีก
คำใหญ่ๆหว่ะอ๋อกูในรูปนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋ซี่โครง
ซี่โครงเนี่ยเป็นอวัยวะภายในสาขา 5 ใครใน
อยู่ข้างในหู
จะกลับได้แล้วนะผู้หญิงน้องจัด
แข็งแข็งหรือนิ่มๆแข็งๆ
หวีใช่ไหมคะตรงๆด้ามหวีน่ะแข็งๆเจ็บ
ตุ๊กตาเนี่ยนิ่มนิ่มๆค่ะหวีนะแข็งๆสีโครง
สีโครงก็เคชิ้นนี้นะคะส่วนที่ไหนคะ
กูอีเลว
สักครู่นะคะได้ค่ะ
ถึงที่นี้ค่ะนี่
ค่ะ
อันนี้ตีโค้ง
มีกี่ชิ้นคะครูย
รีมมากเหรอคะพี่กิตซินเนี่ย 123
ม 4  5  6  7  8  9  10
ล้อ
คู่เอกก็ไม่รู้กี่ชิ้นเอกเอารูปมาแล้วก็
กลัวแต่ว่ามีมากๆ
แล้วก็วาดวาดว่าจะมีมากๆซี่โครงมีมากๆค่ะ
อ่า
อันนี้ก็เป็นซี่โครง
ซี่โกร่งแข็งข้างในสิโครงนะมีอะไรรู้ไหม
คะมีอะไรคะครูเอ๋ข้างในซี่โครงข้างในซี่
โครงมีอันนี้อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียก
ว่า
ปอดหอมมีปลอดเท่าไหร่คะกี่
ชิ้นกี่อัน 2 ชิ้น
แล้วคู่เอก Copy ปอดได้ไหมได้ค่ะอ่ะ
แต่มันไม่ให้คุยกับพี่อ๋อโอเค
คุยกับกิ๊ฟตัวเองน่ะแล้วก็ปอดก็มาไว้ไหน
พี่โข่ง
ปอดอยู่ข้างในซี่โครงใช่ค่ะ
อ้าวหายโอเคไอ้เลยหายไปไหน
หายไปไหนขอโทษค่ะอยู่แค่นึงอยู่ข้างในใช่
ไหมคะ
Bring  to  front เลยค่ะตัวเองโอเค
ไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรอ่ะต้องอยู่ข้างในซี่โครง
นะอยู่ข้างนั้น
แล้วครูเอ๋คะในปอดเนี่ยมีเส้นเส้นมีเส้น
เส้น
อะไรคะเอ็นเส้นเลือดค่ะปุ๊ปโอเคเป็นเส้น
เลือดจะไม่เหมือนนะเนี่ยเหมือนมีอันนี้
เส้นเลือดนะคะ
ก็ก็เป็นปอดนะคะจะอยู่ข้างในซี่โครงอยู่
ตรงนี้เลยเนาะตรงนี้
ก็ออกมาดูที่ปอดปอดอีกนิดนึงมีอะไรอีกคะ
ที่ปล่อยผู้หญิงเห็นอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะอันไหน
คะอันนี้เห็นค่ะครูเอ๋อันนี้ก็เป็นต่อกับ
มาเป็นอันนี้
หลอดอาหารเหรอคะนาย
หลอนอาหารหรือขั้วปอดหลอดอาหารไหม
หลอนอาหารสิเน๊าะคู๋คิดว่าหรอก
ใช่ค่ะคั่วก็น่าจะมีแค่เธอน่าจะอยู่ตรง
นี้ไหมคะขั้วน่าจะดูเป็นออกซิเจนมา 2 อัน
ใช่ไหมค่ะค่ะ
ขอโทษค่ะปอดก็และใช้
อวัยวะต่อไปค่ะครูเอง
อวัยวะต่อไปก็อยู่ในสิโครงนะคะครูยังกอด
วิ่งเคลียร์ของตัวเองให้ค่ะ
ได้ไหมได้ค่ะโอเคเอามายังวะต่อไป
อะไรคะครูเอ๋เหมือน
หัวใจหรอให้หัวใจ
ชมพูเลยนะ
หัวใจเวลาดูสีชมพูค่ะ
คุณหมอหัวใจอยู่ในซี่โครงเหรอคะอยู่ข้าง
ในมีอ่าอะสีโครมมีปลอดแล้วก็หัวใจโรคหัว
ใจอยู่ประมาณนี้ประมาณนี่เองหัวใจอยู่
ข้างซ้ายข้างซ้ายช่วยกูเองมีแหวนแต่งงาน
เนี่ยถ้าสง่าชายหรือข้างขวาคะขอขวดใจหัว
ใจจะอยู่ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะคุยจะว่าตรงนี้
เห็นนะเห็นแคร์แต่กู a ว่าถ้านี่ R
สำหรับผู้หญิงเตะหัวใจ
อันนี้ตรงกลางเนาะค่ะ
ก็จะอยู่ประมาณนี้เนาะไอ้
หัวใจจะอยู่
คุกเอาเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนสี
ก็หัวใจมีสีชมพู
ชายใช่
หัวใจก็จะอยู่ประมาณนี้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
อยู่ตรงกลางนี้คะครูเอ๋อ่าตรงกลางอีหยัง
ไปทางซ้ายต่อทางซ้ายใจไม่ได้อยู่ซ้ายนะคะ
จะอยู่
ประมาณเรียงซ้าย
แสดงคนมีนิดหน่อยเรียงขวาน่าจะอยู่ประมาณ
นี้เช็คได้ไม่มี
ตึกตึกหัวใจครูเอ๋เต้นไหมคะตึกตึกไม่ก็
ได้
ไม่ได้ยินต่อขอ
ลา 888 ถ้าเห็นอะไรแล้วครัวหัวใจจะจุ๊บๆ
จุ๊บๆจุ๊บๆจะ
เอาตอนนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่กลัวหัวใจก็ไม่จุ๊บ
ๆหรือไม่หน้าเห็นโอ้คนหล่อกล้า
คุณรู้เบิร์ตแพททินสันหล่อมั้งมาก
หัวใจเต้น desko ที่
[เพลง]
เกาะหัวใจก็หัวใจคนจะประมาณเท่าๆกำมือ
ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใหญ่บางคนมือใหญ่ก็หัวใจใหญ่เขาครูผู้
หญิงกำมือแล้วไซร้นี้นี้ก็หัวใจครูหญิง
ชายกูเอง
ไม่ใหญ่รู้มาถึงใหญ่กว่ากูเอ
หรอมื้อคุย
มือผู้หญิงสีขาว
ไปค่ะ
เออดูเองมีอีกไหมคะเอาอวัยวะ
ทาย Night มีค่ะอันนี้รู้แล้วเนาะกราบมา /
ค่ะ
กลับฟ้าอาหาร
ขอกลับไปนี่นี่ค่ะ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋
r-oh อันนี้เป็นกระเพาะนะคะอ่านักเรียน
อันนี้กระเพาะอาหารและใต้จอระเพาะอาหาร
กระเพาะอาหารจะมีตรงนี้ต่อก็จะเป็นตัวนี้
ต่อกับอันนี้
พี่อะไรอ่ะครูเอ๋ลำไส้เล็กทำไม
มีเยอะๆไส้คนยาวมากนะกูเห็นทำไม่ได้ยาว
เท่าไหร่แต่อยากเล่าจะออกเพราะมัน
[เพลง]
เยอะมากผู้หญิง
กระเพาะอาหารนักติดกับกระเพาะอาหารกับลำ
ไส้เล็กตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะที่กูเอชีใช่ใช่
เปลี่ยนสีไหม
อันเนี้ย
ลำไส้เล็กค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วอันนี้ล่ะคะอันไหน
คะอันนี้อันนี้
ลำไส้ใหญ่
หอ
ใหญ่กับเล็กมีลำไส้เล็กลำไส้ใหญ่หูน้องมี
อันนี้ด้วยคู่หญิงแล้วอ่ะ
อันนี้ไม่ใช่รังไส้เล็กหรอคะไม่ใช่
แล้วเรียกว่าอะไรไส้ติ่งหู
writing  a ชอบเคมี
ไม่มีแล้วอ่ะ
คู่เอกเคย
[เพลง]
ปวดท้อง
แล้วก็ผ่านแล้วก็ตัดออกไปรอกูเองไม่มีไส้
ติ่งตอนนี้ผู้หญิงมีไส้ติ่งไว้นะไม่มีค่ะ
ไม่มีผู้หญิงก็ตัดออกไปแล้วผู้หญิง Copy
คู๋นะตับให้
ผู้หญิงสวยเก๋ป่ะไส้ติ่่งออกไปแล้วนะคะ
มันมีลำไส้เล็กลำ
มีไซส์ใหญ่ไซส์ติ่งแล้วก็มีอันนี้
อันนี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋อ่ะคือจากไซส์ใหญ่แล้ว
ก็ลงมาตรงนี้เป็นทวารอ๊อดทวารน่ะ
เฮ้ยเอาไว้อ่ะก็จะออกมาเป็น
รอขอเวลากินเสร็จแล้ว
น้องออกจากทวารหนักนายออกจาก
ทวารน่ะค่ะ
มีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋อวัยวะภายในอันนี้คุยว่า
ไม่สวยออกไม่เป็นไรค่ะดูได้อุ้ยอะไรคะครู
เอ๋มีสีแดงสีน้ำเงินสีเขียวอะไรคะชี้ให้
ไม่ผู้หญิงดี 18 แอสีสีน้ำเงิน
สีเขียวห้า
สีสีแดงเนี่ยเรียกว่ากลับค่ะโหดจับใช่
หรือเล็กถ้าครูเอ๋ใหญ่นะใหญ่นะนี่ก็ใหญ่
ใหญ่ตอบอยาก
ตอบใหญ่อยู่นะคะอ่ะถ้าแล้วสีน้ำเงินเป็น
เส้นเลือด
เหมือนที่คิดที่ปอดเพื่อไหมก็มีเส้นเลือด
เส้นเลือดจริงๆคะเด็กเส้นเลือดดำค่ะแล้ว
ก็มีเส้นเลือดแดง
มีเลือดดำเลือดแดงหัวใจก็เหมือนกันนะควร
ใจก็มีเส้นเลือดดำเส้นเลือดแดงแต่งคุณเอ๋
ไม่ได้ใส่เส้นเลือด
ผู้หญิงถ้าสงสัยอะไรคะแล้วสีเขียวล่ะคะ
ครูเอ๋สีเขียวอะไรสีเขียวเนี่ยกูเห็นลบสี
เหลืองสีเขียวใช่ไหมคะค่ะสีเขียวตรงนี้
เนี่ย
[เพลง]
สีเขียวข้างในจะมีน้ำอ๋อ
มีมีเป็นเป็นน้ำค่ะน้ำน้ำสีเขียว
เป็นอ่ะ
เรียกว่า
ใช้ถุงน้ำดีเอาเล็กๆตัวเค้าคู๋ไม่รู้กู
อยู่ดูคิดเล็กๆถ้าน้ำนิดหน่อยก็เล็กๆอ๋อ
ถ้ามีน้ำมากๆก็ใหญ่ใหญ่ขึ้นจะใหญ่มากเล็ก
ๆ
ใช่มั๊ยเค้าจะมีก็มีตับเอาอันนึงเรียกว่า
ตับอ่อนจะส่งน้ำดีนะมาที่ถุงน้ำดีแล้วน้ำ
ดีก็จะไปไปที่
กระเพาะ
หางหมดเนี่ยอยู่ด้วยกันเนาะเดี๋ยวกัน
เกี่ยวกันเกี่ยวกันเที่ยวกันถุงน้ำดีครู
เอ๋ยังโอเคนะมีถุงน้ำดีแต่บ้านทีนักผู้
หญิงฆ่าคนปวดท้องอืดปวดท้องใช่ไหมค่ะต้อง
คิดปวดอะไรยังไม่หมดเห้ยหมดแล้วแล้วเพราะ
ว่าเมื่อกี้อันนี้ลำไส้ใหญ่ค่ะลำไส้ใหญ่
อันนี้สวยในครูเอว่าลุ่ยอะไรคะครูเอ๋อัน
นี้เป็น
อ่ะเล็กๆ 2 เหมือนกันนะคะเล็กๆ 2 อัน
เรียกว่าอะไรคะไก่
ไตยอยู่ข้างหน้าอยู่ข้างหลังอาเดี๋ยว
เนี้ยอยู่ตรงนี้
ไปอยู่ตรงนี้มี 2 บาทมี 2 อันผู้หญิงมี 2
มี 2 ค่ะครูเอ๋ราคาไม่ตัดยางชาติยัง
กูเอกก็มีสองค่ะค่ะแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะครู
เอ๋เหลืองๆเนี่ยอ๋อก็คือเขาเป็นพ่อนะกิน
ท่อลงมาอ่า
ทอดไข่มีน้ำมีน้ำอันเนี้ยหนาวแล้วก็ลงมา
อยู่ตรงนี้
อันนี้น่ะค่ะอันนี้ล่ะคะอะไหล่คะ
อาจจะก็เพราะ
ปัสสาวะ
อะไรกระเพาะปัสสาวะ
น้ำอันนี้ค่ะน้ำหน่อยนะน้ำเป็นปัสสาวะ
[เพลง]
แปลว่าน้ำน้ำก็มาจากไต
มามาแล้วก็อยู่ที่นี่ถ้าอยู่ก็
พระผู้หญิงดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำดื่มน้ำ
เยอะๆลงมาที่กระเพาะปัสสาวะค่ะก็ต้องไป
ห้องน้ำไป
อัศวะไปปัสสาวะ
เอ้าพูดว่าฉี่เหรอคะใช่สองเหมือนกันไหม
เหมือนกันอ่ะปัสสาวะ 4
เยี่ยว
คู่เอกไม่ให้พูดอ่ะเยี่ยวอ่ะเออ
เบอร์โทร ais ภาษาไทยนะคะปัสสาวะฉี่
เยี่ยวเหมือนกันนักเรียนจะได้ยินฉี่มากๆ
หน่อยเนาะ
กรุงเทพฯแต่มีมีมีมีมีถ้าอายก็บอกไป
โทรศัพท์
เทคนิคนะไม่พูดไปฉี่ไม่พูดไปเยี่ยวไม่พูด
ไปปัสสาวะอ่ะพูดไปโทรศัพท์
ไปโทรศัพท์แต่โทรศัพท์อยู่ที่นี่แล้วก็
ห้องน้ำไปก่อนละศัพท์หาของกระเพาะปัสสาวะ
ชายค่ะ
ๆๆมีอีกหนึ่งค่ะ
อุ้ยอะไรคะครูเอ๋
อันนี้เนี่ยชื่อว่ามดลูกโง่
มีรถลูกเนี่ยครูหญิงเป็นผู้หญิงค่ะมีไหม
คะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมีผู้หญิงอ่ะอันนี้ผู้
หญิงอาจไปว่าไทยหมดร่วมเนี่ยผู้หญิงมีผู้
ชาย
มีไหมคะไม่มี
ตอง
ไม่มีมดลูกผู้หญิงมีมดลูกครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่มี
มดลูกครูเอ๋เป็นผู้ชาย
สวัสดีครับ
Toy
เหมือนเมฆรบเหมือนค่ะ
ไม่ใช่กูเอ๋ตัดออกแล้วแล้วผู้หญิงตัด
มดลูกออกโอเคไหมคะก็โอเคนะโอเค
ครูเอ๋มี
มีที่นี่
โอ๊ย
ลูกมีเนื้อเราดิเนื้องอกอ่อนนี้ไม่โอเค
ใช่ไหมคะมีอะไรก็
[เพลง]
มีเนื้องอกรู้ A มีเยอะๆมีมากๆมิ 3 ก้อน
ฮูก่ม
ก็เลยตัดมดลูกเหรอคะใหญ่มากก็เลยต้องตัด
อ่ะออกไปแปลแต่ครูเอ๋มีอันนี้กูหญิง
อันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะมีสองข้างเนี่ยรัง
ไข่
ครูเอ๋มีสองไหมคะน้องค่ะไม่ได้เอาออกต.
เกาะหมดลูกฟ้า
จะออกไปรังไข่โอเค
ครูหญิงขาวได้ไหมถามอะไรคะครูเอ๋ไม่ถามดี
กว่าไหมถามได้ผู้หญิงมีมดลูกไหมคะครูหญิง
ไม่มีมดลูกผู้หญิงมีรังไข่ไหมคะไม่มี
กำลังไข่ครูเป็นผู้ชาย
ครูหญิงเป็นไม่ใช่ครูหญิงเป็นผู้หญิงแบบ
ครูหญิงตัดออกแล้ว
ทั้งหมดเอาออกทั้งหมดไม่มีแล้วก็ผู้หญิง
ไม่ชอบหรอคะให้ชอบค่ะ
อยากฟัง Story  at อาหลานอาพอนักเรียนนัก
เรียนอยากรู้ทำไมครู S บัตรทำไมคุยอิ๋ง
ตัดแอดวานซ์นะคะแอมป์ว่าร้านค่ะใช่หมด
แล้วใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋หมดแล้วจะว่าเวลายังมี
นิดหน่อยไหมคะ
เวลาเวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋คู๋อยากพูดนิด
หน่อยได้มั้ยได้ค่ะได้ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียน
ก็รู้จักอวัยวะภายในมีอะไรบ้างคะผู้หญิง
อะ
อะไรก็หมองสมองค่ะอะไรคะ 4 โครงอะไรคะ
ปอดอะไรคะหัวใจ
อะไรคะระเพาะอาหาร
โอเคอะไรคะหมอลำไส้เล็กอะไรคะลำไส้ใหญ่
อะไรคะ
ไส่ติ่ง
ดับไป
อะไรคะ
อะไรคะถุงน้ำดี
ต่อไปค่ะ
อะไรคะ
ไป
อะไรคะกระเพาะปัสสาวะ
อะไรคะ
มดลูกอะไรคะรังไข่อันนี้อะไรคะ
ท่อรังไข่หรอก็เท่าไหร่ขายได้ท่อนำไข่ลาย
ท่อนำไทยข้างในมีมากๆใช่ไหมคะมีอวัยวะมาก
ๆเวลานักเรียนโอ๊ยโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
เวลาเจ็บก็ต้องคิดที่ไหล
เจ็บอะไรเจ็บอะไรรับรู้เหรอเก่งมาก
โอ้ย
เข้าใจเจ็บอะไรอ๋ออ๋อเข้าใจเจ็บอะไร
คว้าแต่ว่าครูเอ๋เจ็บบ่อยๆเข้าใจเด็กๆนะ
โอ้ยเจ็บไม่เจ็บ
เจ็บจนเข้าใจอ้ออันนี้กระเพาะ
อ้อมอันนี้ไส้เล็กโอ้ยอันนี้ไซส์ใหญ่ก็
อันนี้
ไส้ติ่งโอ้อันนี้โอเคไตไหมอันนี้
มดลูกอันนี้หัวใจ
เข้าใจเหลือกลับยังไม่เจ็บค่ะดีค่ะเอาวัน
นี้โป้นักเรียนก็รู้จักอวัยวะภายในว่า
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะแต่หมดเวลาแล้วครูหญิง
กับครูเอ๋ก็ไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ